was the wife you played kind of an
idealization of the American Wife there
is no such War most of them are
wrestling yes I think we all have our
moments Laura Petri broke down and cried
she was nasty and short-tempered
and she was also sweet soft and she was
many things oh no I think she was sort
of a screened idealization of the
American woman as she thinks she is but
they had no connection with reality
[Music]
Mary Tyler Moore was America's
sweetheart hardly anybody knows comedy
like she does she was just masterful but
she was also incredibly inventive it's
just that I couldn't go to a party
knowing my son was on the verge of being
sick Carl Reiner saw some spark of humor
in me and he started writing for me to
be funny she was on the side of
risk-taking
her morphing into Mary Richards was such
a feminist statement right Tyler Moore
Show hired the most women and it changed
the language of Television women speak
differently and we have different ideas
and we have different stories may you
have the pleasure and joy working with
Mary Tyler Moore
[Applause]
you were kind of locked up the image on
the screen never matched the real Mary
stranger to adversity I had a
miscarriage and when I was in the
hospital they discovered that I had
diabetes
when Richie died that really changed her
just because you have a smile on your
face doesn't mean you're not ready to go
to battle I believe in tomorrow I
believe that things that are painful
will not be as painful in some time
[Music]
the end of the world if I'm not perfect
Mary's book spoke to us women could have
careers could stand on their own two
feet Mary we love you very much
the seven Emmy Awards her three Golden
Globe Awards and her Academy Award
nomination are only the beginning of the
story I think she was meant to spark
fire with a very delicate match women
are or should be human beings first
women second wives and mothers third it
should fall in that order
[Music]